démissionner pour mieux reconstruire
c'est la stratégie politique de giuseppe
compter en quête d'une nouvelle majorité
le premier ministre italien espère
garder la confiance de sergio matar est
là en obtenant un mandat de son
président pour former un nouveau
gouvernement
le troisième depuis 2018 dans un pays en
pleine crise politique et sanitaire
une instabilité accentuée par la
défection du parti allié italien vivats
de matteo renzi le 13 janvier dernier
l'ex chef du gouvernement qui s'est
montré très critique sur la gestion de
la crise sanitaire
ce départ obligé giuseppe comptait
obtenir la confiance des parlementaires
la semaine dernière pour sauver son
gouvernement de coalition
d'abord devant les députés puis au sénat
où il l'emporté d'une courte tête depuis
le premier ministre a tenté de rallier à
sa cause des élus indépendants pour lui
assurer de nouveau la majorité est ainsi
restée aux commandes
son succès pour l'heure le premier
ministre sortant peut compter sur le
soutien du parti démocrate et du
mouvement 5 étoiles mais pour combien de
temps encore